avant de commencer je vous invite à
aller voir la description de la vidéo
dans laquelle vous allez trouver un lien
vers une petite enquête qui va vous
permettre de vous positionner par
rapport à la gauche et la droite dans
son livre le clivage droite-gauche toute
une histoire publiée en 2020 au presse
de Sciences Po Jeannine mosus Lavaux
montre que ce procès est très ancien et
que s'il s'amplifie aujourd'hui c'est
très certainement en raison du
rapprochement des politiques menées par
la gauche et la droite qui conduit à une
offre politique et électorale parfois
peu lisible pourtant les vrais gens
continuent à se positionner à gauche ou
à droite et non ça partir de ces
positions des valeurs et des
représentations du monde social à ces
différentes grâce à différentes enquêtes
qu'elle a menée depuis les années 70
jusqu'en 2017 Janine mosus Lavaux
retrace méthodiquement l'évolution de ce
clivage l'évolution progressive des
idées actives au sein des peuples de
gauche et de droite il s'agit donc ici
de comprendre ce que signifie gauche et
droite non pas en partant de offre
politique ou d'une quelconque théorie
mais bien de la demande c'est à dire des
électrices et des électeurs dans les
années 70 les personnes qui se
revendiquent de droite montrent un
attachement aux hiérarchies et à un
certain ordre naturel un jeune coiffeur
confiait être contre tout le monde à la
même échelle et pour les séparations de
classe j'ai l'impression que si les gens
étaient à la même hauteur ce serait une
espèce de de décadence il faut qu'il y
ait un chef un sous-chef la voye
hiérarchique cette tendance à apprécier
les hiérarchies l'ordre est à mettre en
lien avec un certain goût de l'autorité
la demande de règle est aussi présente
pour ces personnes les règles sont
importantes car elles protègent du
danger que chacun de nous représente
pour la société le travail est important
et on accuse ceux qui apparaissent comme
fainéant on pense aussi que c'est aux
hommes politiques de diriger le pays
chacun a sa place et surtout la femme à
la maison
le progrès mais elle veut pas la
pagaille bref à droite on aime l'ordre
et la verticalité à gauche on veut
l'égalité et pour y arriver on pense
surtout à la lutte des classes un jeune
ouvrier accuse eux l'ouvrier il le voit
pas du tout eux c'est les bourgeois ça
leur est égal que l'ouvrier vive dans un
taudis ou n'importe quoi ils exploitent
l'ouvrier ils s'en foutent de l'ouvrier
carrément en plus de la dénonciation des
inégalités matérielles on ajoute les
inégalités culturelles on veut aussi
valoriser le collectif et améliorer la
situation de ceux qui ne vont pas bien
contrairement à la droite le peuple de
gauche veut l'horizontalité les années
80 sont synonymes de monter de défiance
des gens de gauche vis-à-vis de leur
représentants on croit toujours beaucoup
dans l'égalité mais on n'est pas
convaincu que les parties de gauche en
France en tout cas pourront l'installer
durablement les politiciens bon on a
confiance où on n'a pas confiance ça
dépend mais en tout cas on sait quelque
chose c'est que
il y a officiellement 600 000 personnes
qui ont pas à bouffer en France quoi
tous les jours et les mecs vous disent
ça comme un chiffre et quand on leur
demande qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire pour
pour ça ils disent ben je sais pas alors
nous on sait et on le fait voilà on veut
l'égalité au niveau des salaires pour le
statut des femmes des homosexuels ou
entre les pays du Nord et du Sud
derrière cette exigence égalitaire on
retrouve l'amour de l'humain qui passe
avant toute chose une enquêté déclare la
gauche c'est l'homme au service de
l'homme à droite justement on est à
l'opposé puisque les hiérarchies sont
justifiées et les inégalités ne sont pas
remises en cause on commence à pointer
du doigt l'assistanat qui cause
l'oisiveté celui qui va travailler il va
travailler pour engraisser celui qui ne
veut rien faire les socialistes ils
encouragent les fainéants et pas du tout
le mec qui bosse conclut un ouvrier
celui qui ne fait rien pour monter
socialement ne doit pas être récompensé
on défend la libre entreprise en
considérant que les impôts sont trop
pesants la volonté de hiérarchie est
également de mise pour les relations
homme-femmes et on considère parfois que
la place de la femme n'est pas au
travail une agricultrice à saine le rôle
primordial d'une femme c'est de rester
élevé ses enfants la hiérarchie se fait
également entre les origines en refusant
l'immigration et l'aide aux autres
régions du monde enfin le peuple de
droite demande moins de l'axisme au
niveau des mœurs des jeunes et de la
sexualité trois thèmes majeurs
traversent la droite durant les années
90 il s'exprime tout droit sur le mode
du refus il s'agit d'abord du refus
d'une société multiculturelle
l'immigration trop importante pour être
absorbée est une menace pour l'équilibre
du pays l'arrêt de l'accueil et
l'assimilation des immigrés déjà
présents sont incontournables à droite
une représentante de commerce bretonne
commente on les accueille il ne faut pas
qu'ils viennent [ __ ] la merde chez
nous il faut qu'il s'adapte le foulard
islamique et compagnie Sano je ne suis
pas du d'accord du tout ce qu'on refus
droite le laxisme on veut de l'ordre et
d'abord dans les règles de base le combo
des deux refus de l'Immigration et du
laxisme conduit à une critique farouche
de ce que l'on appelle l'assistanat
que le travailleur français qui habite à
la Goutte d'Or rouge je me promenais
avec Alain Juppé la semaine dernière il
y a 3 ou 4 jours
et qui travaille avec sa part et qui
ensemble gagne environ 15000 francs et
qui voit
sur le palier à côté de son hlm
entasser une famille
avec un père de famille trois ou quatre
épouses et une vingtaine de gosses et
qui gagne 50 000 francs de prestations
sociales sans naturellement travailler
si vous ajoutez à cela
le bruit et l'odeur
et bien le travailleur français sur le
palier devient fou il devient fou c'est
comme ça et il faut le comprendre et si
vous y étiez vous auriez la même
réaction enfin on ne veut pas voir les
traditions familiales disparaissent
cette volonté de transmission est
culturelle mais concerne aussi le
patrimoine ne pas pouvoir transmettre à
ses enfants les fruits d'une vie de
travail et vu comme une infamie l'impôt
sur la fortune est donc contestée et
quand on parle de la gauche elle est
unanimement considérée comme dialiste et
aveugle face à la réalité tandis que la
droite est réaliste responsable à gauche
on reste attaché à ce que l'on pourra
appeler le souci des autres une bonne
part des personnes se déclarant de
gauche disent se préoccuper plus du sort
des laissés pour compte que de leur
propre situation l'exigence de réduction
des inégalités et donc la norme une
enseignante de banlieue revient sur le
vécu de certains de ses élèves à 8h du
matin ils ont déjà vécu beaucoup de
choses
de certains adultes n'aborderont jamais
avoir un papa au chômage une maman en
dépression des problèmes d'argent à la
maison avoir fait le ménage avant de
partir où les courses ou tout simplement
pas déjeuner on s'inquiète de l'avenir
des jeunes et des difficultés qu'ils
rencontreront comme celui des chômeurs
des handicapés des immigrés ou des
femmes qui subissent de nombreuses
discriminations professionnelles on est
également critique envers les
institutions que l'on accuse de
reproduire les inégalités ou de
discriminer les flics les médias et même
l'école sont mises en cause le travail
lui-même est désacralisé et n'est pas vu
à l'instar de ce qui se dit à droite
comme un bien en soi l'argent est très
présent dans les discours des gens de
droite des années 2000 on tente de
gagner de l'argent encore plus d'argent
comme tout le monde déclare un garçon
une femme de 36 ans ajoute je suis pour
l'enrichissement personnel pour que
chacun et mérite selon ses valeurs ou
son apprêtées au travail la valeur
travail est importante et on critique
les dispositifs qui empêchent les gens
de travailler et qui mériteraient dès
lors de gagner plus sans cet appât du
gain on considère que les individus se
laissent aller la jeune femme poursuit
il faut que la société elle aussi
récompense un salaire homérite
redistribution des bénéfices je suis
allergique aux fonctionnaires si vous
dites qu'ils auront le même salaire
qu'il travaille ou pas ils ne vont pas
être rentables de ce fait l'opposition
viserale au profiteur et bien présent
une personne interrogée valide cela il y
a beaucoup de gens qui profitent de la
solidarité pour se la couler douce et
vouloir les mêmes prérogatives que ceux
qui finalement bossent vachement le
rapport à l'argent et les inégalités
sont mis en évidence à gauche les gens
de droite seraient riches et aimeraient
l'argent en tandis que ceux de gauche
aurait un rapport plus distant à
celui-ci est en pauvre ou solidaire avec
les dés argentés
depuis 5 ans la droite a enclenché la
régression des droits sociaux pour
beaucoup la vie est très dure pour la
jeunesse trouvait un travail une bonne
formation c'est le parcours du
combattant la droite tente de précariser
à vie tous les salariés le droit à la
retraite au logement à la santé ses
droits fondamentaux sont dans le viseur
de Sarkozy et de son frère jumeaux ils
veulent construire une société du profit
ou l'humain ne compte plus assister une
qualité sociale s'ajoutent les
discriminations qui portent atteinte à
la dignité des personnes dans le
prolongement de cette idée le
consumérisme est vivement critiqué enfin
les années 2010 clôture cette galerie de
l'évolution de la demande politique à
gauche et à droite le travail et le
refus de l'assistanat sont toujours les
refrains de droite je vous souhaite
porte-parole de cette France qui veut
vivre de son travail
je veux être le porte-parole de cette
France pour qui le travail est une
valeur et qui se désole quand elle voit
le travail déconsidéré quand elle voit
le travail abîmé alors je le dis parce
que c'est la vérité il ne faut pas
travailler moins il faut travailler
davantage on prône une certaine liberté
mais une liberté qui ne serait pas
débridée une liberté avec un peu d'ordre
on pense surtout à la liberté
d'entreprendre à mettre en parallèle
avec une fois sans faille dans le
libéralisme économique on refuse les
replis identitaires communautaires
l'immigration massive et le
multiculturalisme qui fragmente le
commun le respect est toujours une
valeur phare à droite on s'oppose enfin
à l'évolution des mœurs et à certaines
mesures comme la PMA et GPA mais la
droite apparaît comme clivée une
certaine partie prenons une plus grande
ouverture sur ces questions à gauche
cette dernière montre que la valeur
cardinale reste encore et toujours
l'égalité tout le monde est égal on est
donc pour une plus grande justice
sociale un enquêter affirme la naissance
nous crée inégaux c'est un fait mais la
société doit corriger ce fait pour
mettre tout le monde à égalité des
chances petite évolution depuis les
années 70 ce n'est plus l'égalité en
tant que telle que l'on vise mais la
réduction des inégalités l'égalité
semblant inatteignable on prône
également la liberté liberté de penser
de manifester d'agir de publier et même
d'entreprendre je vous remercie pour le
visionnage de cette vidéo si vous avez
des questions n'hésitez pas en dessous
de celle-ci dans le descriptif de la
vidéo vous trouverez également le lien
vers une enquête sur ce clivage
gauche-droite mais évidemment ça aurait
été mieux de la faire avant la vidéo je
vous remercie et je vous dis à très
bientôt dans une nouvelle vidéo de
sciences sociales
[Musique]